estar las tropas rusas deben enfrentarse
a la justicia por supuestos crímenes de
guerra en ucrania eso es lo que dijo el
viernes amnistía internacional en un
informe que incluye pruebas y
testimonios de ataques aéreos ilegales
ejecuciones extrajudiciales y torturas
en la región del noroeste de kiev
living aunque ya sabemos que los
crímenes cometidos contra las personas
que viven en los alrededores de kiev
sobre los que informamos hoy no son
meramente anecdóticos o incidentales o
colaterales sabemos que forman parte de
una pauta que ha caracterizado la
conducción rusa de las hostilidades
desde el principio un patrón repetido de
gran escala e impacto devastador los
kings que el ente 'wasting en impacto
una delegación de la organización
internacional pasó varios días en ocho
ciudades cercanas a kiev con familiares
de víctimas supervivientes y altos
funcionarios ucranianos en boro dianca
descubrieron que al menos 40 civiles
fueron bombardeados en ataques indicó
dos que acabaron con un barrio y ocho
edificios residenciales la investigación
también acusó ejecuciones ilegales en
busca en marzo desde donde se
difundieron imágenes impactantes que
mostraban cadáveres tirados en las
calles y probó 22 casos de ejecuciones
extrajudiciales
también se encontraron los fusiles
exactos que se utilizaron en la matanza
de buzzi que son unidades específicas
del ejército ruso las autoridades
ucranianas afirman que actualmente están
investigando más de 9.000 posibles
crímenes de guerra al igual que la corte
penal internacional que está examinando
las pruebas por su parte moscú ha negado
haber cometido abusos en ucrania
manteniendo que la invasión es una
operación especial